hereditary has been called the scariest
movie of the year and one reason for
that is these creepy model houses like
in this movie it almost the models
almost became a character in the movie
in a sense
Steve Newbern is the owner of Applied
Arts FX studio in Canada he's done
visual effects for the Dark Knight Rises
and inception my team and I we built all
the prosthetics and models for
hereditary if you haven't seen it yet
turn back now because there's some
possible spoilers ahead miniature models
are used all the time in movies filmed
in a way to make them look like a
life-size object usually with miniature
work the intent is not to see it it's
intended to duplicate a real thing but
in hereditary the miniatures were
actually part of the story
Tony Colette's character creates the
models in preparation for a gallery
Steve and his crew were tasked with
making about 15 of them to match the
life-size film sets we had we had a
thousand pieces and at one point and
really didn't know exactly how they went
together the whole process took quite a
bit of time to complete ten weeks with a
crew of about half a dozen people the
buildings included a funeral home a
preschool a hospice and an accident
scene the largest of the models was a
copy of the family home and its
exteriors were modeled after a real
house yeah I went down in 6-8 weeks
before they started filming and just
kind of surveyed the house took you know
several hundred photos a bunch of
measurements that sort of thing he
worked with the director to nail down
all the details flooring they'd sent a
samples wallpaper that would send his
samples all that stuff would be taken
and scaled down to the appropriate scale
the house was built in nine we built the
entire thing as a giant puzzle then
where you can remove sections of it to
shoot from that location the models that
didn't need to resemble the set were
built using generic images online as a
guide like the preschool all of the
furniture was either handmade or 3d
printed depending on the complexity if
there were a wood finish odds are we
actually made them out of wood
if they were something that was metal or
super detailed 3d printed quite often
they had multiple in-house 3d printers
working simultaneously while outsourcing
some of the work they also had to create
some creepy looking figurines of the
characters the people were they were all
3d printed some of them were sculpted
Jonny Quest for example we took that
from digital scan of Tony that we did in
New York the grandmother was a scan of
somebody else the car used in the most
disturbing scene in the movie also had
to look just like the one in the film
the car we modeled and 3d printed it was
a Volvo I believe it was a v70 it's the
exact model car that they used in the
movie some of the models were finished
and then taken apart to make them look
like they were in progress
there was a lot of pieces of furniture
for example that we we'd made that we
just like that let's leave that out on
the side and it's it's on a shelf
somewhere she hasn't quite finished it
that kind of thing another important set
piece was a house sinking into the
ground it was made with card foam and
covered in real dirt and soil it's
supposed to be showcasing time passing
you know and like these things have been
sinking into the ground like quicksand
kind of thing and as they get further
down they're also a lot more
deteriorated after all the hard work
many of the models were ultimately
destroyed by Tony Colette's character as
she starts breaking down don't you ever
raise your voice at me I am your mother
they were all built to be smashed Steve
says that they actually filmed the scene
of her smashing the models which ended
up being cut from the film some of the
ones that were actually intend to be
breakaway are hit squished were built
out of basswood balsa wood other ones
that weren't intended to be smashed were
MDF which was a high density fiber like
cardboard cut but Steve says watching
his masterpieces get destroyed is all
just part of the job it's kind of
run-of-the-mill for the miniature side
of things most of the time when you're
building a miniature it's for the
purpose of it being blown up or smashed
or destroyed in some some respect it's
it's actually the thing you kind of look
forward to
[Music]
you
[Music]